[Musique]
gilbert collard bonjour oui bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur rt france alors on le disait police
et justice
autour de la table aujourd'hui dans un
contexte tendu pour la reprise du
beauvau de la sécurité gérald darmanin
eric dupond-moretti côte à côte pour
montrer que justice et police travaille
main dans la main
contrairement d'ailleurs à ce que
pensent les syndicats de police est ce
que selon vous il faut vraiment
réinventer le lien entre la police et la
justice est ce que c'est une urgence le
côté ya d'abord un fait sur lequel on
est obligé de s'accorder
c'est que policiers et magistrats sont
appelés à travailler ensemble
je rappelle quand même que la police
judiciaire et exécute les commissions
rogatoires que les juges d'instruction
lui donne que le procureur diligente des
enquêtes avec le travail régulier
quotidien des policiers alors cela veut
dire que si les policiers disent d'une
manière collective que la justice ne
fait pas le travail qu'il souhaiterait
qu'elles fassent judiciairement
préventivement pédagogiquement c'est que
réellement il ya un problème on ne peut
pas imaginer une seconde que des
policiers irait critiqué une institution
avec laquelle ils travaillent
quotidiennement
il y a de fait un problème un problème
qui lié à la réponse pénale comme on dit
aujourd'hui qui n'est ni plus ni moins
que la décision de justice 1 face à des
faits récurrents doute rage d'agression
et qui ne sont pas notamment ce qui
concerne les outrages suffisamment pris
en compte par la police
ce n'est pas du pont moretti qui est un
éléphant dans un magasin de porcelaine
des relations entre la police et la
justice qui pourra bien évidemment avec
avec ccc tonitruant grognements régler
la difficulté donc on a véritablement
démocratiquement un problème de de
relations entre deux de te force
essentielle de l'état
la police et la justice qui sont appelés
à travailler régulièrement
quotidiennement ensemble est ce ce
problème doit être réglé par par un
rapprochement par des discussions est
aussi effectivement par une prise en
compte judiciaire du statut du policier
qui qui ne peut plus accepter d'être
traité comme il l'est notamment dans le
cas d outrage en de refaire une
comparaison du res entre les peines pour
outrage à magistrat et les peines pour
outrage à policier déjà ça serait une
indication intéressante alors henri
leroy le sénateur les républicains les
alpes-maritimes représentera aujourd'hui
le sénat aux homos voie de la sécurité
et voyez son avis concernant le code
pénal il faut relier le cordon des
policiers des magistrats dès leur
formation et plus efficacement
qu'aujourd'hui au delà des sanctions en
elle-même il y a le problème du code de
procédure pénale au volume multiplié par
huit en 30 ans il faut le réformer le
dématérialisé à lorsque vous le
rejoignez ce qu'il faut réformer le code
pénal aujourd'hui alors d'abord la
police d'aujourd'hui n'est pas la police
d'hyères les policiers aujourd'hui ont
une formation équivalente à celle des
magistrats
un commissaire de police à le a le
niveau équivalent à celui d'un magistrat
donc
cette espèce de dépendance un peu
hiérarchique du policier au magistrat
n'est pas n'est plus vécue comme pouvait
l'être à l'époque du procès verbal 1
c'est-à-dire où le policier sept ans
quasiment ni lire ni écrire de devait
reprendre sous la plume de quelqu'un qui
savait le faire
le procès-verbal bon donc à une
évolution des relations qu'ils font
quand même prendre en compte le code de
procédure pénale mais c'est devenu une
machine infernale mais infernale les
policiers sont sont enfermés dans dans
une procédure tatillonne qu'il faut à
tout prix mais à tout prix simplifiée il
faut arrêter de voter des lois qui font
que on a un empilage de textes dans
lesquels on ne comprend plus rien parce
que c'est tellement c'est tellement
compliqué il ya tellement de lui dicter
ya tellement de de pièges que les
policiers s'en sont sans épuiser sous la
masse de papier puis puisqu'on parle de
réformes
ne serait-il pas normal qu'on crée un
corps de greffiers de police que comme
les juges d'instruction les policiers
est un greffier à qui il puisse dicter
les procès verbaux alors qu'ils ont
obligé bien que ça ne soit pas du tout
leur formation 2-2 de faire la
dactylographe de police en tapant d'un
doigt ou de deux doigts des procès
verbaux non mais c'est insensé de voir
cela il ya très longtemps que
l'institution policière doit être doté
de ce corps de greffiers de police qui
ferait laitages d'écriture les tâches
matérielles à l'interrogatoire qui dure
huit heures s'ils étaient conduits avec
un greffier de police durée 3h ou 4h il
ya plein de petites réformes à faire et
une simplification évidemment sur le
premier depuis toujours à la demande et
du code de procédure pénal et du code
pénal qui est qui qui qui vraiment
largement suffisant aujourd'hui pour
réprimer toutes les infractions n'en
rajoutait plus surtout n'en rajoutez
plus alors l'actualité gilbert collard
marqué également aujourd'hui par la
visite
du chef de l'état au rwanda l'ambition
est de normaliser les relations
paul quilès le président de la mission
d'information menée par les députés en
1998 sur le génocide des tutsi au rwanda
s'est exprimé sur cette visite et
regardez ce qu'ils en pensent il est
choquant qu emmanuel macron se rendent
au rwanda en diplomatie je comprends
qu'il faille parfois fermé les yeux
je ne reproche pas emmanuel macron
souhait de réaffirmer la position de la
france en afrique et d'y défendre les
intérêts des entreprises mais doit-elle
revenir dans le jeu politique d'afrique
centrale en passant par le rwanda et
paul kagame une personnalité complexe
aux spécificités connu je ne suis pas
sûr que ce soit le bon choix c'est le
bon choix ou pas cette visite d'
emmanuel macron rwanda aujourd'hui on
sait pas forcément d'une dune subtilités
diplomatiques a souligné
je crois que des urgences il y en avait
d'autres là quand on parle du rwanda on
remonte quand même aux années mitterrand
1 et tout son entourage qui entretenait
quand même des relations avec le
gouvernement hutu gouvernement raciste
un pan je ne sais pas ce que monsieur
macro notre président qui passe son
temps à faire pénitence va dire rwanda
mais il serait inacceptable intolérable
qui le met d'un mot en cause l'armée
française dans l'opération turquoise où
elle n'a absolument aucune complicité
aucune part de responsabilité
récemment du reste vous avez un rapport
dit rapport du clerc qui émane d'un
cabinet d'avocats américain qui a été
demandée d'une façon neutre qui écarte
toute complicité de la france dans le
terrible insupportable génocide qui a
été qui a été commis au rwanda vous pas
d'excusé pour vous aujourd'hui un imac
on doit pas donner d'excusés aujourd'hui
au rwanda et quand sarkozy était allé au
rwanda il avait reconnu des erreurs d
aveuglement
que que mitterrand et son entourage on
était en période de cohabitation et
commis des erreurs et des aveuglements
c'est possible mais l'armée n'a en aucun
cas la moindre responsabilité la plus
petite complicité dans ce génocide du
reste les rapports qui ont été établies
le prouva je rappelle quand même que le
juge trévidic avait mis en avant dans en
avance la responsabilité d où tout bon
il serait il serait insupportable que
que le président de la république chef
des armées à y reconnaître une
complicité ou une faute qui n'existe pas
alors concernant les régionales à
présent gilbert collard l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner s'est exprimé sur votre parti
qu'ils jugent raciste et il a souligné
l'importance d'un front républicain au
second tour dans les régions où votre
parti sera présent regarde je fais la
différence entre des adversaires
politiques et des gens qui ne vise pas à
soutenir la république et sont plutôt
dans un comportement antirépublicain en
permanence alors gilbert collard vous
lui répondez quoi christophe castaner je
ne prends pas très au sérieux l'homme
d'aider des boîtes de nuit un monsieur
monsieur castaner en fait républicanisme
il est mal placé quand on voit la
manière brutale parfois inhumaines un
don il a réprimé les manifestations ddj
les jeunes mais cette complainte du
racisme ils vont nous la resservir à
longueur d'élections ils n'ont plus que
ça ils n'ont plus que ça et et castaner
qui est un perroquet politique inquiète
qui passait de la gauche seront pente à
la république en marche en se faisant
virer du poste de ministre en ce en
pleurnichant pour être président de
groupe n'a aucune autorité pour dire
quoi que ce soit à quoi bon mais c'est
vrai que en vingt ans on va nous traiter
de raciste on va de nouveau
recommencer cette rengaine et ce seront
les pires qui vont le dire les pires les
bornes year de gilet jaune
voilà qui vient parler de républicanisme
bon c'est de la politique c'était de
tout le monde sait que cela est
absolument faute absolument mensonger
mais ils vont essayer c'est vrai et
castaner chi chi chi prêt qui est prêt à
dire tout et n'importe quoi bon et le
canonnier delà de la diffamation voilà
bon moment donné des aliments dits
faudrait de poursuivre je leur ai dit
écoutez on poursuit pas le vide abyssal
anisé d'un d'un personnage comme lui
quoi bon c'est se dire que c'est quand
même dommage que la politique soit
représentée par des parts des costards
comme castanet revoilà puisque j'ai à
dire je lui accorde pas plus
d'importance franchement merci
gilbert collard d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes député européen du
rassemblement national